non-minimalists
what aspects of fashion align with
minimalism's goal of intentionality
i have seen the two put at odds with
each other more often than not
especially with the rise of
environmentalism but think that there
must be some way to show clear
intentionality through your personal
style
so mckinsey i think that when we're
talking about fashion again this is a
good question for this because i think a
lot of our malls
especially in the 90s and the
audi's and even in well not even but
especially
in the 20 teens we need a name for that
decade i
was thinking the teenies maybe because
i like the genies i always call the the
90s the audience
yeah maybe the tinnies i don't know yeah
we'll figure it out let us know on
youtube yeah right
it works for everything 2000 teenies
works for everything yeah 2013
to 2019. right anyway yeah so so
somewhere in the 2010s there fashion
really became this fast
fashion thing right yeah and and there's
no intentionality in fast fashion let's
let's just say that now here's the
problem i have i'm a hypocrite
because i i wear clothes that i suspect
i i mean probably not right now i don't
know i actually i don't know
and here's the thing um i am when you
look at your average american i'm
i'm more intentional than 98 maybe even
99
of the the populace with respect to my
fashion i try to get things that are
made in america
yeah uh i try to get things that are
even made locally and i get things that
will last me so i'm willing to pay a
little bit more i also buy things
without logos
and with that whenever possible there
are occasions where there might be a
really tiny logo on something that i
can't avoid
or i'll even remove logos whenever i can
yeah these
shoes i'm wearing here i'll hold it up
for the camera
man these are really beat up but these
are these are tom
you know that reminds me we got this
idea from david didn't we
david who um we stayed with him and his
girl
in san diego oh yeah yeah tooth adams
yeah and he
hit tooth adams that's right on twitter
and he uh he had a pair of toms and he
was removing
i remember him removing the tom's label
when we were there remember that but
the reason i did it i had a levi's um
let's see what's called a denim jacket
right that i got off ebay
and here's the ebay hack for that you
can get levi's denim jackets on ebay for
like
four to nine dollars nice but you have
to buy like
three or five of them in order to find
one that fits you right you just buy
them one at a time unless
you get the right one that fits yeah and
and but
i often do even now i'll do this with
different shirts and things
is you can buy new or next to new
clothes
uh that someone bought and they just
didn't enjoy it for whatever reason
they're selling on ebay so
even with my levi's jackets i would
always just take the tag off because i
don't
that company isn't paying me to
advertise for them i wouldn't do it
anyway because advertisements suck
but so what am i going to do pay them
for the privilege of advertising being a
walking billboard on on my body
yeah there's no way i'm going to do well
that's just the genius of marketing in
this brand recognition thing how
people want to advertise the brand
because that says something about how
much you paid for something where you
stand you know on the socioeconomic
ladder
what kind of click you're part of what
kind of style you have
um but if we're relying on a brand to
express who we are
uh we're just expressing that we we
don't really think for ourselves
yeah yeah yeah i would encourage you to
go back and check out two episodes we
did
uh number the first one is episode 56 a
long time ago ryan and i were living in
montana we did a clothing episode it's
one of our longer episodes
and it's just about clothing episode 56
and then more recently
we did an episode called fashion
obsession with tyler jones from
preachers and sneakers
we talk about our sort of obsession with
fashion but to get to your question more
directly
mckenzie i think the problem we've
gotten into is we've built these
bastions of consumerism that have
required us to consume
more in order to fuel their pockets
their their bank accounts the
their corporations their ceos their
executives and
so what do they do it used to be that we
had
two seasons warm and cold
and so in the winter we had a coat or
maybe we had slightly thicker clothing
or a sweater or whatever but now
you have places like h m or other fast
fashion places
that do 52 seasons a year right
and they call them drops right and so
and they do it in ways where it's like
limited edition
trendy clothes well if something is
trendy to me that's a red flag
right away right trendy just means soon
to go out of style what does that mean
you have to replace it yeah and if you
have to replace something constantly can
you imagine ryan if
if you bought your your toyota that you
own and
and i don't know let's say that once a
quarter you had to paint it
yeah because like there's a new cool
paint job that was in style yeah i would
buy a better
quality car right right but and here's
the thing though
it doesn't doesn't mean the paint job
was bad
we get rid of the clothes now because
it's like well that paint style
that that outer layer the paint style is
now no longer
fashionable it's no longer involved well
you know what's interesting though you
know i think that
you can intersect fashion and minimalism
uh
you can totally be fashionable and still
be a minimalist uh i would encourage
um what's her name mackenzie to check
out
project 323 with courtney carver she
hasn't checked that out but yeah
in fact we did an episode with her
recently uh within the last year yeah
project 333 she has a book of that same
title yeah
some of the best dressed people at our
events some of the most fashionable
people at our events are
doing project 333 almost always and
that's the thing because when we talk
about intentionality well what is it
it's the deliberate use of the resources
that we have
and i think one of the best places to go
shopping is not at the mall
right they're dying anyway by the way
you don't want to go to mall right now
regardless right but but
you want to go shopping in your own
closet yeah because
start there yeah you have things in your
closet i did this
i know this is weird timing this is a
total coincidence but this weekend i did
it
in my own closet i have i got rid of me
i who owns next to nothing
i have a whole trash bag right now one
shirt one pair of pants
and 67 jackets
[Laughter]
i'm wearing four jackets right now
you have a trash bag full of uh clothes
to go donate yeah wow
sadly nothing more jackets oh i can't
let go of my jackets
no i i i get rid of jackets all the time
we're all hypocrites man yeah
here's the thing though like so i was
talking about the hypocrite thing
earlier
is i'm very intentional with my clothes
but
still 93 of factory workers
in the united states who work under osha
conditions
often in unions often with a really good
minimum wage and other
fringe benefits 93 of them say they work
in sweat shop-like conditions
wow 93 of american factory workers
garment factory workers and so yeah it's
it's staggering because
even though i try really really hard to
be intentional you can only be so
intentional because the next step for me
would be what to
make my own clothes which i'm not going
to do yeah again like those corporations
they're responding to
the demand yes yeah we need we need to
demand different things
right and so i i recommend finding
things that are more timeless when i say
something that is timeless it means
for your lifetime will it wasn't in
style last year will it be in style next
year maybe that's the
the the good benchmark uh and so it
could be basic colors ryan and i often
wear just black but
if purple is your color then great
accent
your stuff with dude if i look good in
purple or blue or i would buy different
colored t-shirts but i just
happen to like the way i look in black
you look great ryan so that's what i
wear
every single day what i feel best in
yeah i'm not gonna switch up my shirt
because
you know my sister tells me that i look
like a goth
and she's tired of my style look at
anyone that you
that you find to be stylish from
a decade or more past so for ryan
and me that could be like paul newman or
steve mcqueen or someone like that
um and and for women it could be you
know
jackie o and uh uh whoever marilyn
monroe
whoever it might be there are plenty of
uh oh um
who's the novelist that i absolutely
love uh joan didion
joan didion is you know she was a style
icon
look at what she was wearing that stuff
would work today
the problem is the the hype of today
would have never worked back then but it
doesn't say supreme
how do i know i'm supreme if i don't
wear supreme mackenzie i'm going to send
you the supreme book
it's called essential essays by the
minimalist it's a collection of 150
different essays 12 different areas of
intentional living
and one essay in here has to do with
clothing about the favorite clothes of a
minimalist i think you'll enjoy that and
the 149 other
essays that are in that book if you like
our podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of that or any of our books
or we'll send you the book book or the
ebook version if you'd like